[Music]
again i didn't understand the gravity
until
after the performance and it is heavy
because
you're celebrating but you know there's
still so much inequality not just for
women of color but white women as well
so as
amazing as that moment is and i
appreciate it and i receive it like we
still have a lot of work to do
look at the country radio charts and see
that there's only one woman in the top
20 right now
or even i have a new song that i'm still
struggling to get on the chart
what are you gonna tell her when she
figures out that all this time you built
her up just so the world could let her
down
i know that the the awards were a
socially distanced affair
what was it like having keith urban up
there oh my god
we were rehearsing i forgot the lyrics
to my own song a couple of times that
was so
i remember i was like so nervous and
then i look over at keith
who's a guitar player you know he's not
a piano player and he
looked at me and his hands were shaking
like this and i was like
what are you doing i'm nervous i'm the
one that's supposed to be
more nervous they always say never meet
your heroes but
keith who is such a gracious human being
like he's been through so much he's so
pro-supporting women and just a kind
person and he helped with those nerves
musically mickey has nothing to worry
about her new ep bridges has received
rave reviews
[Music]
but those nerves may return for another
reason mickey is expecting her first
child
early next year pregnancy hits different
for everybody
and everybody has their own experience
about how they feel
what's yours been like so far i was just
in complete shock like it's terrifying
it was not an
instagramable moment when i found out
that i was pregnant
like i looked at that pregnancy stick
and was just like
exactly what the hell am i doing
but i was also scared that the baby was
going to affect my career
which was a horrible i had a deep
program my mind to think that
as a woman i can have a family and have
a career too
so i'm trying to be as honest about my
pregnancy as possible
and the fears that i've legitimately had
i'm not
you know reading a thousand books on how
to be a mother
i don't even have my registry started i
don't have a nursery i don't have
anything
i'm for i'm over four months so i'm just
gonna give myself grace
to to know that i'm not gonna be perfect